is basically the same thing as alcohol
it's alcohol in a pill why are there
blackouts with Xanax like sugar Gaba
receptors are responsible for memory
converting short-term memory to
long-term memory and anxiety your brain
uses the same pathway just your brain's
trying to be efficient some highways are
combined they have dual function or
multiple functions
out different stuff yeah your pictures
that pee in your dictions outcome so
your Gaba receptor is responsible for
anxiety and it's responsible for
short-term memory converting to long
term so that's why when you drink you
brown out and black out and when you
take Xanax you brown and blackout
because you're tampering with the same
receptor that's responsible for memory